we live in the most politically
polarized time since the Civil War
Americans have sorted into two mutually
exclusive groups Democrats and
Republicans or liberals and
conservatives and we agree on absolutely
nothing without a common culture the
United States is rapidly descending into
a war of all against all and may God
have mercy on our souls well not exactly
more is Pia Fiorina a political
scientist at Stanford and the Hoover
Institution regrets to inform you that
you are absolutely mistake in his latest
book unstable majorities Fiorina mounts
a convincing argument that Americans
actually agree with each other on many
if not most fundamental questions the
polarization we hear about all the time
is he says largely restricted to
political activists and media elites who
mistake their own extreme views for the
voice of the people in reality Fiorina
says voters are not more extreme or
polarized than in the past
rather it's the political parties who
have pushed out to the far right and far
left and their nominating candidates who
represent fewer and fewer Americans why
that's happening why it's troubling and
how it might be changed are the topics
we'll be discussing today marce FIRREA
thanks for talking to Reason I'm glad to
be here let's start with the title of
your book unstable majorities you know
early on that the four consecutive
elections between 2004 and 2010 produce
four different patterns of political
control of the federal government so you
know the White House Congress the Senate
all flip around in different ways since
2000 we've had two people who lost the
popular vote but won the presidency
these are extremely atypical events
what's going on here well I think it's
very interesting we're in a historically
unusual time generally speaking there is
a majority party in the United States
there is no majority party today in
every election each of our three
national offices the presidency the
house and the Senate are basically up
for grabs it's only eight years ago the
Democrats had the House of
Representatives the Senate is always on
a knife edge and as you point out we've
had two very close presidential
elections where the popular vote winner
lost and then and you talk about how
even in 2000
for which was funny when I was reading
the book I was like a bush one that
easily but actually it was pretty close
yes and 2008 was not exactly a blowout
either correct even though the party won
everything it didn't win everything by a
lot there has not been a presidential
landslide in quite a long time whereas
when you think back there the previous
generation we saw Eisenhower in 56
Lyndon Johnson in 64 Nixon in 72 Reagan
in 1984 we haven't seen anything like
that in a long time
yeah and for a long time there was I
mean Bill Clinton in 92 won with 43
percent is extremely low yes so why is
this happening our parties have
traditionally been catch all parties in
majoritarian systems like ours you
typically have a two-party system where
both parties are broad-based we don't
have that anymore we have two parties
now that look like the Social Democrats
and Christian Democrats in Europe at the
late 20th century when they were very
very dominant and you have two parties
in a big heterogeneous country where
people have all kinds of points of views
that don't necessarily hang together and
it's simply not enough to represent
diversity in this country so two parties
two parties is not enough to represent
330 million people exactly and the point
is because they're so homogeneous when
one party wins it attempts to impose an
agenda on their country which is often
not the same issues that the country
thinks are the most important issues
facing the country and also more extreme
positions on the issues that it does
take place on you but in order to win
the parties have to appeal to centrist
or independence and you write argued
note that it's about 40 percent of the
the country identify as independence so
in an election season the at least at
the presidential level typically a
Democrat or a Republican will kind of
move to the center to win but then once
they're in power they go to the edges
yeah it's getting harder and harder in
today's wired world for a party to move
to the center because they have you on
film and on the air everything but I
think it's fair to say we have if you
take turnout into account we know how
the one-third one-third one-third party
system if the Democrats have a third
Republicans a third and third or in the
middle so you win the election by
captain
the Lions here in the middle but then if
you impose a agenda that's your basis
agenda a lot of the people in the middle
say I didn't really vote for that and
they abandon you in the next election
you know I asked the co-authored a book
a couple of years ago called the
Declaration of Independence where my
colleague and I Matt Welch made the bold
argument that independence mattered the
most one of the common criticisms that
we met was you know there really are no
true independence and you know people
are just kind of bullshitting when they
say I'm not a Republican or I'm not a
Democrat to pollsters are their true
independence and how do we know they're
out there yeah there definitely are I
mean it's clear that some are closeted
parties as there have always been some
people who just like to say I'm an
independent but the this idea that all
independents are closeted partisans or
even the lion's share of them is greatly
exaggerated if you look at how
independents vote they very very more
across time for example they switch
their votes whenever a third party vote
candidate appears independents are much
more like even the independent leaners a
much more likely to go for the third
party so it's it's the true proportion
of true independence I think is unknown
but it is enough that it determines the
election yeah because if you're talking
about you know forty six percent versus
forty eight percent winning the
presidency you know that means three
percent of the vote it's gonna make may
break somebody exactly and how does that
play out it one of the most interesting
things and we'll talk more about the
2016 election in a minute but you know
so many counties it seemed or districts
that voted for Obama twice then voted
for Donald Trump is that a sign of
Independence or is that a sign of kind
of cloudy thinking on the part of the
electorate well I think first of all
we'd have to look and see just how big
the changes in the new counties were
maybe if they went from 51 to 49 and
doesn't represent a huge change where
that is what one of the things that
happened in the popular vote but I think
it reflects the instability that in
contrast a lot of commentators you say
Americans are walked in these two camps
no I don't think it does the same kinds
of people who voted for Obama in 2012
come back and say I want to vote for
Trump this time those are people who are
not really Mord
to either of the two parties part of
what I found fascinating about unstable
majorities is you're
kind of understated venom towards most
party activist most political activists
and especially political journalists
such as myself for not knowing what the
hell we're talking about in 2004 this
happened and again in 2006 where you saw
it first Republicans when Bush won won
re-election and did okay and you know
the Republicans said okay but you saw
people talking about locking in the
permanent Republican majority a couple
years later when that all ended suddenly
people were talking about well it's
going to be the Democrats for the rest
of our lifetime why or I guess I know
why party activist it's kind of wish
fulfillment or projection there so they
when they win any election they said
we're gonna win them all why are
journalists and even a lot of political
scientists so short-sighted in in the
ways in which this stuff flips and flops
and back-and-forth in defense of my
political science colleagues I don't
think that many of us actually said
these are these are landslide earth
shattering realigning elections I think
journalists is say talk too often to the
to the activists they talk to the people
who won and there's a kind of trampled
ism on the part of either of the either
of the winning parties which then
filters through the journalists let me
just say something about filter bubbles
by the way this is a big thing in the
news that everybody worries about the
average American being is constant a
filter in public well in fact the
average American doesn't follow news
very much at all that most the research
suggests that it's the elites who are in
these filter bubbles
it's the elites who only talk to each
other and who have this simply jaundiced
or not jaundiced prejudiced or none when
I'm over to my having totally by an
array of illusions yes world and you
know for example I'll give a talk and
I'll put some data up and say here's the
percentage of Republicans who believe in
abortion or who believe in gun control
and I'll get emails back saying I don't
believe your data I don't know any
Republicans who believe that and those
are the people in the filter bubble they
don't talk to anybody you have some I
mean incredible stats and one of them
and said you in terms of kind of diehard
Democrats they think 44% of Republicans
make over 250,000 dollars a year which
is hilarious and then this is I might
even be better Republicans think 38% of
Democrats are lesbian gay bisexual or
trans where you know why is that
happening
now as opposed to I mean it seems so out
of touch what what is fueling that kind
of completely ridiculous view of the
other side I think first of all I should
just say those statistics were produced
by some of our graduate students who
have access to a polling firm here and
we all were armed mind boggling we saw
those figures but I don't think we can
say for sure but a lot of it surely has
got to be TV that TV and the Internet
everybody else the media in general
practice what's called exemplification
they say we want to have a Democrat and
then they start the award what's a
Democrat well it's a protester a
minority you know I there are people
down here at Town and Country who
purchased the 65 year olds with long
gray ponytails you know and then you
want a Republican okay you want to be
somebody suit and tie you want to be
maybe a new evangelical or something and
so in the fact that socially we're much
more segregated than we used to be when
I was growing up though we do live in
more homogeneous neighborhoods etc
although again that's exaggerated but I
think people don't they simply don't get
out and know the other side and so you
get this picture from the media and the
picture is simply not very accurate it's
exaggerated it's not just from the media
them and I'm thinking about recent books
like our kids by Robert Putnam the
Harvard sociologist and the charles
murray and we're coming apart coming
apart where they you know and these are
two guys who disagree with each other
although they come to common kind of
analyses of what's wrong in america and
one is you know that you know
everybody's living in a bubble and how
do you know then that like regular
americans are not in an ideological
bubble the way that you know the elites
are saying they are oh well this is
personal that i come from as we were
talking about pennsylvania which is a
heart of trump country and i think my
county voted something like 96 percent i
know they're like honeys 96 percent
white
they voted more than two-thirds for
Trump and I go back and I talked to
relatives and cousins and so forth and
they aren't the kind of the stereotypes
you would see about what those kind of
people would look like as you see in the
media and so I mean partly it's just
personal that there aren't many people
in either academic or certainly the
people who appear on CNN who sort of
actually have any experience talking to
America in the flyover country what are
the areas where
there are large you know majorities
where people on culture war issues where
Americans actually agree but then the
way that it gets filtered through the
political process people are like now
this is you know absolutely we're at the
barricade sure the the these social
issues are the best example that most
Americans can basically take row as it
is out there and say I can live with
that
right that they don't want to outlaw
abortion they're a little uncomfortable
with some of the third TriMet well more
than a little uncomfortable third
trimester stuff but basically they can
say we can live within this middle
ground
same thing with gay rights on the one
hand they don't want to see a baker
forced to make a cake for a wedding oh
god they don't want to see they want to
see gays have equal equal rights so they
basically can sort of be in a
comfortable little grind big majorities
of guns are another thing most Americans
can even NRA members can scan sort of
support what are called common-sense gun
control but the other yeah in each case
these we have activist groups in each
party's base the pro-choice pro-life
pro-gun and a gun Pro gay rights
anti gay rights which make it which
espouse much more extreme positions than
two populations the whole and so this
means it's always interesting with
abortion because if you go back to the
early seventies it wasn't clear the
party split on that but there are now I
don't think there are any Republicans in
Washington who are pro-choice nor are
there any Democrats who are pro-life or
maybe one or two you know how did that
become acceptable because I mean so the
parties have sorted and you have these
incredible charts where it shows that
you know compared to 50 or 60 years ago
there's no variety in the parties
they're you know with the Republican
Party is a conservative party the
Democratic Party is a liberal party why
did they sort that way what what change
that we wouldn't have catch-all parties
you know that's a great question we
don't have a good answer I tried to
address that in my middle book
disconnect I published in 2011 I think
and in some cases you can point out
demographic changes really explain it
for example we have a great the internal
migration of african-americans from the
south to the north and that pushes the
northern Democrats in a more liberal
direction on social welfare and civil
rights
that intern alienates more of the south
and the publican is sort of look at that
and see an opportunity you can tell a
demographic story it's something like
that but on the other hand if you were
trying to guess before abortions on the
agenda
okay abortion is gonna be a big item
which party is going to be pro-life most
people said well probably the Democrats
they're the Catholic party they're the
evangelical Baptist party and yet it
doesn't work out that way
and by the same token environmentalism
that the environment the Republicans
have a long tradition of being
conservative party with Teddy Roosevelt
things like the Audubon Society and the
Sierra Club Republicans sort of upper
middle class Republican organizations
why do they sort out the other way and
they Democrats meanwhile blue-collar
workers whose industry is polluting
right so I think we really don't have a
good handle on how it has to do with the
activist groups of social groups but I
don't think we have a good handle of all
on just how the sorting occurred and
then the large question though is or the
large point is that once the parties
have sorted there's really no way I mean
if you want to vote if you want to be a
voting citizen you really don't have
somebody who is it and if you're a
normal American which means you're
somewhere in that middle you don't
really have a party that represents you
mmm yes there's a good chart in the book
on that yeah so why why do people pick
you know but people then end up mostly
voting you know I don't get in the
presidential election laws and maybe
three or four percent didn't vote for
either Republican or Democrat how do we
choose to say I'm a Republican or on the
Democrat there's a long political
science literature on this both in
Europe here that the wasted vote thesis
that you know there's really only two
choices and so you don't want to throw
your vote away and that's why the
proportion voting for who say they're
going to vote for a third party always
diminishes as he get near the end but I
mean it's yeah it's a funny situation
you've got a vote for a party that's
wrong for you on one or more issues that
I I always say we live in an area here
where thousands tens of thousands of
young professionals who are struggling
to get by and continually vote for
people who are going to raise their
taxes because the alternative is wrote
for a vote for a party that says we're
gonna bash gays restrict abortion and
log the Redwoods you know and so so in
that situation they're gonna vote for a
party that really doesn't represent
their economic interests what about the
you know there is that idea that you
know
demography is destiny in politics and
the younger Americans Millennials are
you know if you want to say people under
40 or whatever you know are obviously
gonna vote Democratic from here to
eternity because you know because of gay
rights because of immigration because of
drug legalization things like that
is there a reason to believe and
certainly at least going back to
certainly to Obama I mean the Democrats
have totally cleaned the clock of the
Republicans when it comes to younger
voters are the Republicans just out of
touch with young people and will never
win them back or what what happens with
it yes they are out of touch with young
people as far as never winning them back
I never say never yeah that in politics
was that Harold Macmillan he said a week
in politics is an eternity and at one
point you two said well you know
Catholic is gonna vote Democratic
forever and then this Catholic social
position change they start voting
Republican much more and more and I
think the same thing is true of all the
demographic things at some point you
know I've often said parties can be
stupid but they don't stay stupid
forever and at some point there are
there will be new leadership cadres
coming up in Republican Party who will
say we got to take stock of what this
country looks like now it doesn't look
like it looked like in the late 70s or
80s when all the social issues in the
social groups and and those are kind of
when the contemporary identities or the
current identities of the Democratic and
Republican parties were founded and and
those coalition's don't really exist
anymore cells right we're left with this
hangover of these the husks of old
coalition's that don't really speak to
anything here that's that's right it's
true interestingly around the world I
mean some other countries are ahead of
us for example the whole basically
French party system just collapsed the
Social Democrats disappeared and so guy
without a real party yes because rather
suddenly and see that the problem in the
United States is we don't have our
institutions keep a macron from riding
to the rescue than what happened in
France but this is happening around the
world that these these calcified old
party systems that just don't fit
today's issues and today's concerns are
coming apart what can we learn from
previous period to in the book you talk
about the period of no decision in the
late 19th century where it you know
party control went back and forth back
and forth
time you know a Democrat would win the
presidency Republican Congress
vice-versa what what ended that to lock
in you know Republican dominance and
then Democratic dominance etc for any
period of time what ended it in was 1896
when a Republican want everything and
they governed in a way the population
found acceptable and he kept on winning
they won for fourteen second years and
stayed the majority party until the
depression at that point the Democrats
came in and governed in a way the
population found acceptable now over hat
we're seeing today is nobody governs in
a way that for two years that the
population finds acceptable and they
whack you in the next election and that
seems to be you know that's on the table
for later this year in the midterm
election exactly so you know the parties
have sorted and then at one point you
talked about Donald Trump may be a
disorder what does that mean and it's
like is that a good thing or a bad thing
well I think it's a good thing anything
that the fractures the current party
system is a good thing and I've been
saying this and hoping for it for more
than a decade but just doesn't hasn't
happened but the fact that you remember
when Donald Trump comes in and starts
emphasizing issues like being anti trade
etc or different foreign policy a more
American first foreign policy he's
attacked by the conservative leaders who
say he's not a true conservative and
that that is how they define the
Republican Party as being this party a
true conservatives and I think what they
found out too much of their dismay in
many cases was that a whole lot of
Republican voters are not true
conservatives that they're not sorted in
the same way that the elites are and so
they found his trade policies acceptable
in some cases they found his more
isolationist foreign policy is
acceptable and I think the same thing is
true in the Democratic Party but you
need to sort of end up may have a
candidate who sort of is off the sort of
main diagonals of the party so yeah if
Trump is like that with the Republican
Party and I can see your point and and
he's moderated to a certain degree has
moderated his stance on immigration and
whatnot he soon was a little less you
know he's no longer talking about
kicking out eleven million people and
all of that kind of stuff although he
hasn't walked it all back but on the
Democratic side the insurgent candidate
who really gave Hillary Clinton fits
with Bernie Sanders who seemed to be a
exaggerated form of what a Fox you know
of what Sean
he thinks all Democrats are um is there
somebody who would be a disorder for the
Democrats that's on the horizon
I guess off the top of my head I don't
see it but on the other hand if you ask
me six months before Trump entered the
race is there a Republican I couldn't
people about either so maybe it'll be
Oprah maybe there could be someone who
just comes in and sort of takes a
different position on some of the
identity issues the social issues and
finds there's a real path there all
lanes so to speak there after the
election in 2016 and you have a good
deal of fun with this but you know
observers many observers mostly
journalists were saying things like
American democracy is doomed
Trump's election was an American tragedy
you know will we be able to stop the
obvious rise of fascism
why are those sentiments so ridiculous
okay well the first thing was they
overlook the fact that according to all
the full date we have Americans thought
they had a historically bad choice
that people don't realize how poorly
Hillary Clinton was regarded by a large
part of the American electorate and gal
fears and others showed that Trump was
the worst candidate worst ordinary
candidate in modern history Hillary was
to that Trump had the grand everybody
they were the only two in one chart that
you have who who had disapproval ratings
above 50% records that that Trump
complete obliteration this is like that
season when Sammy Sosa hit 66 home runs
but Mark McGwire hit like 72 this was
just like a legendary setting season
yeah probably both now that I think
about it Hillary and Trump are both
probably using steroids as well yeah it
could be and and people knew what they
were getting in Trump if you look at the
poll data again they didn't think Trump
was qualified they didn't think Trump by
the right temperament but they voted for
him anyway in many cases yeah and one
part of the book you talk about when
there are these moments of instability
it often comes along with there are
there are larger factors going on things
like globalization or transformation of
the economy how is that playing out here
and what are those main factors that
would you know would give Americans who
were generally you know I mean we might
not be that smart but we're not that
stupid either what what are those large
events that are giving rise to setting
our kit we'll take a chance on Trump
okay well I
mentioned these in conjunction with the
parallels of the late 19th century when
you have large-scale
economic and social changes going on and
then it was the Industrial Revolution
today it's this transition to a
communications or an informational
economy then it was population movements
from the farms the cities in recent
years it's been the frost Belt the Sun
Belt both are years of mass emigration
more globalization it's an ongoing
process but it surges at various times
and when you have these kind of changes
going on they create dislocations there
are new winners there are also new
losers they strain the old coalition's
that they don't they've previous allies
are now in tension or with each other
they create opportunities for new
politicians and basically it just
creates uncertainty political
uncertainty you know libertarians a
reason is a libertarian organization
libertarians are sometimes described as
socially liberal and fiscally
conservative which also seems to be kind
of the way that you and and you know
gallop every survey kind of shows that
that you know most people are you know
somewhat moderate some are it centrists
and I realize describing libertarians a
centrist might set some people's hair on
fire but you know we want people to be
able to live the way they want but we
also and we want a government that is
vaguely competent but it's not doing
everything is a libertarian sensibility
something that describes this centrist
American voter this modal American voter
or you know what what is a term that
would do that more okay following the
some of them I mean in contrast to
political elites where basically they're
on a left-right scale most public
opinion analyses find two dimensions
they find this economic in this social
dimension and there are the liberals on
both and the Conservatives on both who
are happy with the two parties and in
their two off-diagonal groups and one is
libertarians soft libertarianism that
favors sort of economic prudence and
minimal government but social liberalism
the other is they call populist who are
sort of the opposite they favor the
social welfare program is the safety net
and also more conservative on the social
issues so they're in a sense two
unaffiliated group well they're
affiliated but loosely with the two
parties and I guess at this moment
though either of those groups can really
play a big role in yes in election said
it's clear that populist took the you
know
I mean they they they won the day in
this most reason that's right happen a
lot depends on the candidates and and it
happened there was there was a vehicle
Trump for the populist movement to come
to impulse coca-cola that I wonder I've
always wondered what if bill weld had
been the top of the tail libertarian
ticket I mean I was in Massachusetts
when weld was governor and I have great
admiration for him and so had well been
on the debate for example and well been
the nominee you might have seen the
expression of the libertarian impulse
coming out simply because but otherwise
they had no there was no worth for that
and go and I guess weld also it he
represents that you know what type of
Republican who no longer exists right
that northeastern Republican who's who
would be called a moderate maybe a
country-club Republican but yeah that
person doesn't exist anymore correct
social type how much of what's going on
in American politics is reflective of
global trends because you know we hear a
lot and you write about this in the book
you know that populism is on the march
in England and in Europe and it's always
you know the lights are always going out
in Europe in this case should we be
worried or maybe that's the wrong term
is is European populism and American
populism are they linked or are they
independent phenomenon they're linked
through their the common cause which is
the underlying social and economic
change is buffeting the societies I was
at a conference in Rome a couple months
ago where scholars from all over Europe
their and that the commonalities work or
clear that all over Europe masses are
concerned about immigration and the
European elites have tried to keep the
lid on this in the same way or at least
try to keep the lid on civil rights for
a long time and it's bursting out now
because non traditional parties are
taking up the mantle of those what about
the social welfare state I mean
obviously Europe has a more robust
the kind of set of safety net or social
security programs that we do you know
but this is all like are we at the end
of the age of Bismarck of the idea of a
social welfare state that is funded by
having lots of younger people who are
funneling you know relatively a lot of
people funneling money to relatively few
people and obviously demographically now
every country and the industrial
industrialized world especially Japan
but also in Europe and in North America
we just can't support the
and you know on some level people
understand that Social Security is
already running an annual deficit that
Medicare is running out of money etc and
it is the anxiety about that coming up
in either in the form of being
anti-immigrant because they're seen as
takers as as opposed to people
supporting the system or we just
realized that whatever we're doing here
it's you know it's it's effectively over
it's just a question when the clock
stops well I don't know which to choose
but I can certainly tell you from
talking these other scholars that part
of the I mean you have welfare states
that are under pressure just from
budgetary reasons just the age of
austerity but clearly a lot of the
anti-immigrant sentiment reflects the
fact that immigrants are straining
additionally straining the social
welfare system prettier if Muslim women
don't work for example that's a source
of resentment in some countries and so
so that ties into what these things are
all tied together and whether it's how
it's going to in a fight I'm just not
going to speculate it does in American
politics this foreign policy ever really
matter that much if there is a shooting
war if people are dying and increasingly
if we're just acting as advisors and
only only a few people from flyover
country are dying then it doesn't make
it into the national media but I mean
yeah I mean if we're into a serious war
I mean yeah Vietnam for example in 68
the economy's booming we're producing
war materials I was working in the
litter of steel mills in those days we
were working seven days a week and
getting over time but still Johnson and
Humphrey lost the election Wallace made
hay and a lot of it was just because
there was a war lots of young men from
those kinds of areas we're dying
what about terrorism are we at bunam and
I realize now I'm throwing a lot of kind
of spit balls here but is the age of
terrorism you know obviously it exists
we still talk about it a lot but the the
9/11 effect is that fading because that
seemed certainly that was one of the
ways that George Bush won reelection in
2004 but in an hour you know 12 13 years
after that is terrorism no longer or
that kind of national security question
as relevant as it was was I think not
but there their set of issues like
school shootings terrorist attacks that
have this effect that when it happens in
the immediate surge and then a quick
decay and I think we're see we're it's
amazing what a society can become
accustomed to and regarded as sort of
normal the occasional shooting the
occasional terrorist attack so I but I'm
who's to say what would happen with
another gigantic attack where 3,000
people died that might take a while to
deteriorate a final question
let's we're you know some months out
from 2018 the midterms what what is your
best guess you know we're in an era of
unstable majorities right now the
Republicans on the White House and both
houses of Congress what's going to
happen in November okay well just on the
basis ie without looking any data right
after the election I would have said the
Democrats chart chances of taking over
the house are good because they only
need 24 seats and in recent memory
midterm elections that's well within the
well within around one possibility
the Senate's a much steeper climb of
course because they're defending so many
seats and so many seats that are in
Trump country and I still think that's a
pretty reasonable projection that the
Democrats have a good seat good chance
in the house not nearly as good a chance
in the Senate but a whole lot depends on
things in the meantime if there are if
there are terrorist attacks for example
and the economy is it's interesting that
typically the things that determined the
midterm losses are the president's
performance and economy which usually
run together
the president has regarded highly or not
be becomes an economy that's an
interesting situation where Trump's
numbers are pretty bad but you want to
be just perking along right and so again
from a political science standpoint this
is a chance to sort of separate these
two factors which is sort of nice well
we will leave it there we've been
talking with Morris P Fiorina of
Stanford and the Hoover Institution is
most recent book is unstable majorities
Morris thanks so much for talking
you're very welcome for reason I'm
Nikolas be
[Music]